si les choses étaient aussi simples que
vous veniez de les exposer pourquoi
est-ce que l'iran et l'ayatollah comédie
dont vous avez dit qu'il avait atteint
deux objectifs importants ont condamné
l'intervention du nom soviétique en
afghanistan en disant que c'était une
atteinte à l'indépendance mêlée ça mais
ça c'est d'affaires de ces d'affaires de
communes issa tomeny sepang communiste
et raisonnent pas pourquoi cet homme là
le plan de l'indépendant bien m'écouter
vous vous posez une question qui ne
s'inscrit pas du tout dans le débat
raisonnement je vous mets non moi je
vous pose la question est ce que oui ou
non les forces existent aujourd'hui pour
imposer la paix mais j'ai dit oui et je
dis que la première de ces forces
c'est l'union soviétique bouvier de
matériaux m'avait dit j'ai vu brejnev où
j'ai vu break
il était comme vous êtes devant moi en
aussi bonne forme il a fait un exposé et
son premier exposé a duré une heure une
heure et quart nordiste ce que voulais
te dire reflète un peu ce que vous avez
entendu sur la lutte contre
l'impérialisme progression ça me manque
et je discute avec vous avec vous mais
mes parents non mariés pas comme ça vous
arrive on n'en parle jamais vous avez
pas vous mettre dans votre petite tête
que moi aussi j'ai un cerveau et un
cerveau pied capable de raisonner de
réfléchir et formuler des propositions
et des appréciations touche aux stups
ongles je ne suis pas obligé d'aller
chez je devais poste à prendre les
espaces et animations j'ai dit oui dans
ma petite tête val combien je vais à
l'étranger je discute j'écoute et cetera
mais je suis quand même je sais je suis
peut-être qu'un ouvrier à mon dieu mais
je suis un militant ouvrier qui avec mes
camarades intellectuelle dans son parti
est capable de procéder à des analyses
qui tiennent debout
d'ailleurs dire sans vous être contre
l'aja dote ses deux brochures sait les
rapports qui gonâve que j'ai fait au
congrès et la résolution vous avez vous
verrez ça a été fait au mois d'aout au
mode de mars avril ça
généreux et bien vous verrez c'est la
justification de ce qui se passe
maintenant bonbons